My name is Diakalola Amujam. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK. the Clean Sight application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book, as everyone's story was different
我叫 Diakalola Amujam。我刚从爱尔兰心理学专业毕业。我也是一名有志成为临床心理学家的学生。Marion 博士的书《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中对我帮助很大。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，我发现这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学申请流程的深入信息，这非常有用。我很喜欢阅读那些已获得资格和正在接受培训的临床心理学家的经历。书中的各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不尽相同，
and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. You graduate with a psychology degree. Your friends are starting graduate schemes, earning decent salaries and posting about promotions, and you're applying for assistant psychologist roles, getting rejected and wondering if you've made a mistake. Today I'm joined by Sam Adam, a university careers consultant, to talk about what no one else seems to explain clearly enough. Why the psychology career path looks different, why assistant psychologist roles aren't entry level,
它为临床心理学之旅提供了令人惊叹的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。你获得了心理学学位，你的朋友们开始参加研究生计划，拿着不错的薪水，并在社交媒体上发布升职的消息，而你却在申请助理心理学家的职位，不断被拒绝，并怀疑自己是否做错了选择。今天，我邀请了大学职业顾问 Sam Adam，来谈谈似乎没有人能解释清楚的事情：为什么心理学职业道路看起来与众不同，为什么助理心理学家的职位不是入门级职位，
and how to use your university career service properly both before. and after you graduate. Because you are not behind, you just need the right support to help you to move forwards. I hope you find this so helpful if you do, please like, comment and subscribe for more.
以及如何在毕业前后正确利用大学的职业服务。因为你并没有落后，你只是需要正确的支持来帮助你前进。我希望你觉得这很有帮助，如果确实如此，请点赞、评论并订阅以获取更多内容。
Hi, welcome along to the podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Today I am joined by Sam Adam, who is a careers consultant at Brunel University. Hi, Sam. Hi, Marianne.
嗨，欢迎来到本期播客。我是 Marianne Trent 博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天和我在一起的是布鲁内尔大学的职业顾问 Sam Adam。你好，Sam。你好，Marianne。
Lovely to meet you. And thank you for being here and thank you for pitching, kind of pitching yourself to me, because we got chatting my email this time and I was like, this sounds really interesting, I'd love to have you on. So thank you for reaching out to me. I know we are speaking today because you happen to work at Brunel University, but you're not acting for them or speaking for them. Absolutely, yes. Any views that I expressed today are mine alone. and but as you say, I happen to work at Brunette University, yeah.
很高兴见到你。感谢你来到这里，也感谢你向我毛遂自荐，因为我们这次是通过电子邮件聊上的，当时我就觉得这听起来非常有趣，我很乐意邀请你参加。所以谢谢你联系我。我知道我们今天交谈是因为你恰好在布鲁内尔大学工作，但你并不是代表他们或为他们发言。当然，是的。我今天表达的任何观点仅代表我个人。但正如你所说，我确实在布鲁内尔大学工作，是的。
Perfect. Thank you. So I, you know, I was flabbergasted when you told me what you do because I genuinely had no idea that your job was a thing. And maybe that's because when I was at university, it wasn't. But actually you work with students who are doing their degree or their, you know, postgraduate study and you have the capacity, capability, ability to work with people post-graduation as well, don't you? Yeah, that's right. Yeah. So from the minute our students arrive in their first year of
太好了。谢谢。所以，你知道，当你告诉我你的工作内容时，我感到非常震惊，因为我真的不知道你的工作是真实存在的。也许是因为我在上大学时还没有这个职位。但实际上，你与正在攻读学位或研究生课程的学生合作，而且你也有能力在他们毕业后继续为他们提供服务，对吧？是的，没错。所以从学生大一入学的第一分钟起，
undergraduate studies, we are trying to connect with them in any way that we can through employability lectures and obviously our social media and lots of different employability events that we run and then we offer the service once students have graduated for up to three years. And I think that's really important, especially for psychology students. So I work with three different cohorts, psychology being one of them. And my psychology students are the ones that book in more once they've graduated for help with applications to training programs, PhDs, master's courses. Once they go away and get their work experience and then need help with making those
我们就通过就业讲座、社交媒体以及我们举办的各种就业活动，尽一切可能与他们建立联系。然后，在学生毕业后，我们还会提供长达三年的服务。我认为这非常重要，尤其是对于心理学专业的学生。我负责三个不同的群体，心理学是其中之一。我的心理学学生在毕业后预约寻求帮助的次数最多，主要是为了申请培训项目、博士学位和硕士课程。当他们去积累工作经验后，需要帮助来完成这些
applications so I see a lot of psychology students who've graduated which is wonderful yeah I mean I think we're a pretty special breed I won't lie but yeah like it sounds really really lovely and I think especially for people that may not have family support or or may not have family that have been through education or or don't understand psychology because it is very different I think isn't it yeah yeah it's it's very different compared to to say my economics and finance students who, you know, will maybe want to get onto a graduate scheme when they finish.
申请时，我看到了很多已经毕业的心理学学生，这太棒了。是的，我的意思是，我认为我们是一个非常特殊的群体，我不会撒谎。但这听起来真的很棒，尤其是对于那些可能没有家庭支持，或者家庭成员没有受过高等教育，或者不了解心理学的人来说，因为心理学确实非常不同，不是吗？是的，是的，与我的经济学和金融学学生相比，这确实非常不同，他们毕业后可能只想进入研究生计划。
And I think it can sometimes be a bit confusing and unsettling for psychology students when they hear their friends who are studying, maybe business or something and they're like, but I need to be getting onto a graduate scheme now. And there's a lot of unpicking, I think, to be done to help them realize that actually your path might look a little bit different
我认为对于心理学专业的学生来说，当他们听到学习商业等专业的朋友说“我现在需要进入研究生计划”时，这有时会让人感到困惑和不安。我认为需要做很多梳理工作，帮助他们意识到，实际上你的道路可能看起来与
to your friends who are studying perhaps more business. focused subjects and going into those graduate schemes or graduate jobs. So it's it's quite different and I think it's it can be a really confusing range of jobs to understand. I mean obviously your focus is clinical psychology. My students, many of them want to go into clinical psychology, but you know it could be psychological well-being practitioner or psychotherapist or any of the mental health roles that are out there and it's it can be really overwhelming trying to understand the differences between them all for students. So, but, but you know, I really enjoy working with my psychology
那些学习商业相关科目并进入研究生计划或研究生工作的同学有所不同。所以这非常不同，我认为要理解这一系列工作可能会让人感到非常困惑。我的意思是，显然你的重点是临床心理学。我的学生中，许多人想从事临床心理学，但你知道，也可能是心理健康从业者、心理治疗师或任何现有的心理健康角色。对于学生来说，试图理解它们之间的区别可能会让人感到不知所措。所以，你知道，我真的很喜欢与我的心理学
students. So I'm always really happy to see them. Oh, nice. So yeah, the podcast, I am a clinical psychologist, obviously. And so it's going to probably be heavily weighted towards clinical psychology. But we've got a special season, which probably has already happened, looking at educational psychology, by the time this one comes out. And we do look at relevant roles. And I basically think about it as being anything that you can do post-psychology graduation and just having people that are psychologically informed out there in the world, I think is no bad thing. Yeah, I absolutely know what you mean because when I was an aspiring psychologist myself, so post-graduation, some of my friends were at the time on salaries that felt pretty nice.
学生一起工作。所以我总是很高兴见到他们。哦，真好。所以，是的，这个播客，我显然是一名临床心理学家。所以它可能会严重偏向临床心理学。但我们有一个特别的季节，在这一期播出时可能已经结束了，专门探讨教育心理学。我们确实会关注相关角色。我基本上认为，任何你在心理学毕业后能做的事情，以及让世界上有具备心理学知识的人，我认为都不是坏事。是的，我完全明白你的意思，因为当我还是一个有抱负的心理学家时，也就是刚毕业后，我的一些朋友当时的薪水感觉相当不错。
And I was on about £13,000 a year. And sometimes I was working six days a week. to get that salary. It really, I don't know, you have to really care about the work you do and the people that you're doing it with. And it's just a bit rubbish, really, that you don't always get the new remuneration that, you know, you should ideally receive. And I know salaries have increased somewhat since I was an aspiring site, but yeah, it's definitely looking around thinking, well, they are earning nice money, their clothes are, they're nice, they're able to kind of move out and live independently and I am not any of those things. Yeah, and I think that's a really important point and it sort of comes back, I suppose, to
而我一年大约只有 13,000 英镑。有时我每周工作六天才能拿到那个薪水。这真的，我不知道，你必须真正关心你所做的工作以及与你共事的人。而且，你并不总是能得到你理想中应该获得的报酬，这真的很糟糕。我知道自从我还是个有抱负的心理学家以来，薪水有所增加，但是的，环顾四周，看着他们赚着不错的钱，穿着漂亮的衣服，能够搬出去独立生活，而我却什么都没有，这种感觉确实很复杂。
career, people's own career values, you know, what is important to you in a job? And is it making a difference for other people? Is it developing your own learning? Is it financial security? that there are lots of different things that matter to different people and those can change over time. But it's an important part of what we try to do as career consultants to try to help people to understand what their career values are and what is important to them at any given time. Because, yeah, there's a big difference. Yeah, there really are. There really are.
是的，我认为这是一个非常重要的观点，它在某种程度上回到了人们自己的职业价值观，你知道，工作中什么对你来说是重要的？是为他人带来改变吗？是发展你自己的学习吗？是财务安全吗？对不同的人来说，有很多不同的事情很重要，而且这些事情会随着时间的推移而改变。但这是我们作为职业顾问试图做的事情的重要组成部分，即试图帮助人们了解他们的职业价值观以及在任何特定时间对他们来说什么是重要的。因为，是的，确实有很大的不同。是的，确实有。确实有。
And before we hit record, I was saying that I'm obviously a terrible economist, economist is the term. I was a terrible economist because I make about £45 a month from this podcast and yet it costs me many hundreds of pounds and I've done this for four years. And so I'm clearly doing this because I passionately care about this content being available. But yeah, like if I was doing economics or if I couldn't afford to bankroll this myself, I'd have had to have stopped it, right? Yeah, it's, and I think that's, I don't know if this is an unusual segue, but whilst you were talking now, I was just thinking, well, that's why it's so important to get work experience whilst you're going through university just because it's important for you to find out what you enjoy, which challenges you enjoy and, you know, is that what you want to do rather than making a lot of money? from the outset when you leave university because it, the decisions, we all make decisions at different times and we're all ready to understand ourselves
在录音开始前，我说过我显然是一个糟糕的经济学家，经济学家这个词。我是一个糟糕的经济学家，因为我从这个播客中每月大约赚 45 英镑，但它却花费了我数百英镑，而且我已经做了四年了。所以我显然这样做是因为我热切地关心这些内容能够被获取。但是，是的，如果我是在做经济学，或者如果我负担不起自己资助这个项目，我就不得不停止它，对吧？是的，而且我认为这是，我不知道这是否是一个不寻常的过渡，但当你刚才说话时，我只是在想，这就是为什么在大学期间获得工作经验如此重要，仅仅是因为你需要找出你喜欢什么，你喜欢哪些挑战，以及，你知道，这是你想要做的事情，而不是在离开大学时就赚很多钱？因为，我们都在不同的时间做出决定，我们都准备好了解自己
and what we need at different times, but that earlier you can start taking part in experiences, that earlier you're going to start understanding what is important to you and which challenges you thrive on and what it is that you want to be contributing to the world than what you want to keep learning about. So yeah. Yeah, I never planned to work at uni, but I did.
以及我们在不同时间需要什么，但你越早开始参与体验，你就越早开始了解什么对你来说是重要的，你擅长哪些挑战，你想为世界做出什么贡献，以及你想继续学习什么。所以，是的。是的，我从未计划在大学工作，但我确实做了。
So I didn't work in my first year, but during my summer holidays of my first year, the student support service wrote to me, because I was a psychology student and said, actually we've got these roles called student support workers who go with people who've either got permanent disabilities or transient disabilities like broken arms or broken legs to facilitate them getting to their lectures and to be able to stay in them and take notes
所以我大一没有工作，但在大一的暑假期间，学生支持服务部门写信给我，因为我是心理学专业的学生，他们说，实际上我们有这些被称为学生支持工作者的角色，他们陪伴那些有永久性残疾或暂时性残疾（如手臂或腿部骨折）的人，帮助他们去上课，并能够留在课堂上做笔记
and engage fully with their curriculum. So it was a one-to-one service. And so they invited me to apply and I did and I got the job. And I did really value what I did. And at the time they'll pay me £6.50 an hour, which at the time was a really good, really good rate. Yeah. And so I learnt quite a bit, I would say, in that role. even though it wasn't something that I was planning on applying for.
并充分参与他们的课程。所以这是一对一的服务。他们邀请我申请，我申请了，并得到了这份工作。我确实非常重视我所做的事情。当时他们付给我每小时 6.50 英镑，这在当时是一个非常好的报酬。是的。所以我认为我在那个角色中学到了不少东西，即使这不是我计划申请的工作。
So yeah, I would say, yeah, if you can, do consider working. But obviously it does take away some time then from your ability to be able to study. It's interesting that I would then have to get up for nine o'clock lectures, which were not my own, which was a bit of a kicker. But then once I was up, I was more likely to be at uni and I had time to study and to do things. And it was interesting when I got together with my friends who I used to live with at uni. And it's now been 26 years since we started uni. But I was talking about this job when we got together in Cambridge for a weekend to celebrate our 25 years.
所以，是的，我会说，是的，如果可以的话，请考虑工作。但显然，这确实会占用你学习的时间。有趣的是，我不得不为了九点的讲座起床，那不是我自己的课，这有点让人沮丧。但一旦我起床了，我就更有可能去大学，我有时间学习和做事情。有趣的是，当我与我在大学住在一起的朋友聚在一起时。距离我们开始上大学已经 26 年了。但当我们为了庆祝 25 周年而在剑桥聚会时，我谈到了这份工作。
And I was talking about the job that I had. And all three of them were like, you worked at uni. Did you? I've got no memory of that. And I was like, well, you definitely knew. You must have known. It's probably because you were all guys, you guys were all asleep when I was getting up and going to these lectures and doing things and I'd just meet you at uni later. So yeah, you might well be struggling doing all the stuff, but it's for you and it's for your own journey and to support the people that you work with.
我谈到了我做过的工作。他们三个人都说，你在大学工作过？真的吗？我一点印象都没有。我说，好吧，你们肯定知道。你们一定知道。这可能是因为你们都是男生，你们都在我起床去上这些讲座和做事情的时候在睡觉，我只是后来在大学见到你们。所以，是的，你可能在做这些事情时很挣扎，但这是为了你自己，为了你自己的旅程，为了支持你共事的人。
But everybody else may not even notice. Bless you, yeah. And that's a really important. point is that I know a lot of students have jobs, often sort of full-time jobs, a long-time, full-time study. So, you know, I appreciate it's really difficult. And that is the kind of thing that your careers consultant, that you will have a careers consultant, whichever university you're at, can help you with. You know, one of the things that I sort of recommend to my students is the text-based service shout. And I don't think they're taking new recruits at the moment, but, you know, that's something that you can fit around, you know, the other responsibilities that you
但其他人可能根本没有注意到。天哪，是的。这是一个非常重要的点，我知道很多学生都有工作，通常是全职工作，长期全职学习。所以，你知道，我很理解这真的很困难。这就是你的职业顾问，无论你在哪所大学，都会有职业顾问可以帮助你的那种事情。你知道，我向我的学生推荐的一件事是基于文本的服务 Shout。我不认为他们目前正在招募新成员，但是，你知道，这是你可以围绕你其他责任来安排的事情，
have and even if you're just doing an hour here an hour there you are building experience that's going to be helpful and there are lots of responsibilities you can take at university so at Brunel we have peer mentors where you sort of support new students with their study skills and I just think anything that you do that is supportive of people in any way shape or form builds upon that bank of experience that you've got to help take you to the next level if you want to work in mental health. Someone once described it to me as a ladder and I think that's a really good way to look at it. You know, maybe you start working at Tesco's on the customer service desk,
即使你只是在这里做一小时，在那里做一小时，你也在积累经验，这将是有帮助的。在大学里你可以承担很多责任，所以在布鲁内尔，我们有同伴导师，你可以在那里支持新生的学习技能，我只是认为你所做的任何支持人们的事情，无论以何种形式，都在积累你所拥有的经验库，以帮助你提升到下一个水平，如果你想在心理健康领域工作的话。有人曾经把它描述为梯子，我认为这是一个很好的看待方式。你知道，也许你开始在乐购的客户服务台工作，
you're helping the supermarket shoppers and then, you know, maybe you do some mentoring or something and you're helping people with how to study and then you're sort of moving up the ladder all the time. So, you know, that job that you did at university sounds absolutely perfect. Yeah, and it was paid. I'm aware that also universities, certainly I speak for Warwick, University, because one of my friends works there, they'll have departments that support students with their mental health and with their well-being. And so there might well be paid opportunities there where you can get involved with doing more mental health aligned work that helps you and, you know, helps your fellow students at university. Is that something that all universities
你在帮助超市购物者，然后，你知道，也许你做一些指导工作，你在帮助人们如何学习，然后你一直在向上爬。所以，你知道，你在大学做的那份工作听起来绝对完美。是的，而且是有报酬的。我知道大学，当然我代表华威大学说话，因为我的一个朋友在那里工作，他们会有支持学生心理健康和福祉的部门。所以那里很可能有带薪机会，你可以参与做更多与心理健康一致的工作，这有助于你，你知道，帮助你在大学的同学。这是所有大学都必须有的吗？
have to have? Do you know, Sam? All universities will have some kind of service and it varies at universities are as a university we went we went through quite a big restructure last year so our services have changed um but then yeah there may there may be opportunities and if not it's always helpful i think just to go and talk to the people that work there to find out about their jobs as well it's another source of information to help you start making up your mind about what what type of mental health work would i like to do so even a conversation is an amazing start But yeah, I think universities all have some kind of well-being service. Yeah, okay, thank you. It's just reminding me of when I was looking for jobs and I was a postgraduate.
你知道吗，Sam？所有大学都会有某种服务，而且在大学里会有所不同。作为一所大学，我们去年经历了一次相当大的重组，所以我们的服务发生了变化，嗯，但随后，是的，可能会有机会，如果没有，我认为去和在那里工作的人交谈以了解他们的工作也总是有帮助的，这是另一个信息来源，可以帮助你开始决定你想从事什么类型的心理健康工作。所以即使是一次谈话也是一个了不起的开始。但是，是的，我认为大学都有某种福祉服务。是的，好的，谢谢。这让我想起了我找工作的时候，当时我是一名研究生。
I went to university in Glenmorgon in South Wales, which is now, I think, called University of South Wales. But I stayed in really regular contact with my academic supervisor for my dissertation. His name was Martin Graf. And he was lovely, but I feel like I asked him for more references. than anyone else in the world. So I was always really nice to him and stayed in contact with him and was telling him when I'm moving on and all of this jazz. And I think he probably breathed silent sigh of relief when I started a master's and then relinquished him of any reference responsibilities. But, you know, university academic staff, it's run of the mill. It's part of it for them, whereas some people are like, oh, people won't remember me or, you know, they won't know who I am.
我在南威尔士的格伦莫根大学上学，我想现在叫南威尔士大学。但我与我的论文导师保持着非常频繁的联系。他的名字叫 Martin Graf。他很可爱，但我觉得我向他索要的推荐信比世界上任何人都多。所以我总是对他非常好，并与他保持联系，告诉他我什么时候要继续前进，以及所有这些事情。我想当我开始攻读硕士学位并免除他任何推荐责任时，他可能松了一口气。但是，你知道，大学学术人员，这对他们来说是家常便饭，这是其中的一部分，而有些人会觉得，哦，人们不会记得我，或者，你知道，他们不知道我是谁。
And, you know, if they don't know who you are, then I would say, make sure they do know who you know who. you are so that when they're writing a reference, they can speak honestly about you and your aptitude for psychology. Yes, thank you for making that point because it's something we are always trying to remind students, make sure that you get to know your tutors because sometimes, you know, because we're quite a visible service, well, fairly visible service, students are able to book one-to-one appointments with us so they do ask, can you write a reference for us? but we can't because we don't have that insight into the work that they've done.
而且，你知道，如果他们不知道你是谁，那么我会说，确保他们知道你是谁，这样当他们写推荐信时，他们就能诚实地谈论你以及你的心理学天赋。是的，感谢你提出这一点，因为这是我们一直在提醒学生的事情，确保你了解你的导师，因为有时，你知道，因为我们是一个相当显眼的服务部门，嗯，相当显眼的服务部门，学生们可以和我们预约一对一的咨询，所以他们确实会问，你能为我们写推荐信吗？但我们不能，因为我们对他们所做的工作没有那种深入的了解。
And I think it can be easy to not build that relationship with your tutor, but it is important to do that. So they can comment in positive ways, rather than just saying the general, yes, this person attended, but if they don't know you, it's difficult for them to be able to comment. And I'm sure that your tutor will be really delighted to see the progress that you've made.
而且我认为不与导师建立那种关系很容易，但这样做很重要。这样他们才能给出积极的评价，而不是只说一些笼统的话，比如，是的，这个人参加了课程，但如果他们不了解你，他们就很难做出评价。我相信你的导师会非常高兴看到你所取得的进步。
Because when you, well, I can only speak for myself when you work in a university and you support people and then people achieve what they want. It's that's why we do the job. So I'm sure your tutor will be very happy to see how you've managed to get where you wanted to be. Yeah, and I think it's just, it's really lovely. When I think back to some of the people who did teach me,
因为当你，嗯，我只能代表我自己，当你在大学工作并支持他人，然后人们实现了他们想要的。这就是我们做这份工作的原因。所以我相信你的导师会很高兴看到你是如何成功达到你想要的目标的。是的，而且我认为这真的很棒。当我回想起那些教过我的人时，
so there was Alan Granfield and Lance Workman and then Martin Graff. And you know, these people stay with you. They become part of your psychologist. identity even when you move on. So it might be that people are listening to this podcast or watching it on YouTube and they're like, I know that person, I know them. And they've been part of my experience and my journey. And I think that's a real gift. You know, people tell me that sometimes when they're preparing for interviews, they hear my voice and think that I'm on their team or even people that I've worked with in person when I was in the NHS. They're like, well, you're still
有 Alan Granfield、Lance Workman 还有 Martin Graff。你知道，这些人会一直伴随着你。即使当你继续前进时，他们也成为了你心理学家身份的一部分。所以可能有人正在听这个播客或在 YouTube 上观看它，他们会说，我认识那个人，我认识他们。他们是我经历和旅程的一部分。我认为这真是一份礼物。你知道，人们有时告诉我，当他们准备面试时，他们会听到我的声音，觉得我和他们站在同一边，甚至是我在 NHS 工作时亲自共事过的人。他们会说，嗯，你仍然
you're still with me, you know, what would Marianne say? And I think that's the biggest privilege. Yeah, that's really lovely to be part of people's stories like that. And another part of the service that the universities do offer is mock interviews. So for anyone who's got an interview coming up, and if you're still within the time that you can access the career services at the university, then know that you can probably book in for a mock interview. And, you know, the people that I work with tend to say, you know, I feel much more confident. now that I've done it like that. And it can be nerve-wracking.
你仍然和我在一起，你知道，Marianne 会怎么说？我认为这是最大的荣幸。是的，成为人们故事的一部分真的很棒。大学提供的另一项服务是模拟面试。所以对于任何即将参加面试的人，如果你还在可以使用大学职业服务的时间内，那么要知道你很可能可以预约模拟面试。而且，你知道，与我共事的人往往会说，你知道，我现在感觉自信多了，因为我已经做过这样的练习了。这可能会让人紧张。
Even to do a mock interview, you know, often people say, oh, you know, I'm feeling really nervous. You know, I'm not there to judge. I'm not there to give you a place, not to give you a place. I'm just there to help you improve what you say so that for the real interview, you can smash it.
即使是进行模拟面试，你知道，人们经常说，哦，你知道，我感到非常紧张。你知道，我不是在那里评判你的，我不是在那里决定是否录取你的，也不是不录取你的。我只是在那里帮助你改进你的表达，这样在真正的面试中，你就能表现出色。
And so, yeah, that's something to look into if you've got any interviews coming up. Absolutely. And, you know, I think that the more experience you can get of doing interviews, the better because you're more likely to get those tumbleweed moments. in the mock one rather than the real one. That's why in the aspiring psychologist membership,
所以，是的，如果你有任何面试即将到来，这是值得考虑的事情。当然。而且，你知道，我认为你获得的面试经验越多越好，因为你更有可能在模拟面试中遇到那些尴尬的时刻，而不是在真正的面试中。这就是为什么在“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划中，
I'm trying to do regular kind of examples of interview Q&A's so that people are having a go at that because I think there's also something incredibly powerful about learning to hear your own voice and taking up room and taking up space and knowing that it's okay to have an opinion and when your opinion is formed based on your own values, your own experiences, or whether you're backing that up with kind of research and clinical practice. And for me, it's only really when I've
我尝试定期进行面试问答示例，以便人们进行尝试，因为我认为学习倾听自己的声音、占据空间、知道拥有自己的观点是可以的，以及当你的观点是基于你自己的价值观、经验，或者你是否用研究和临床实践来支持它时，这本身就有一种极其强大的力量。对我来说，只有当我
begun to speak out loud and to take myself seriously and not quinge at the very idea that I would have an opinion or people would want to listen to me is when you start to begin to rise, I think. Yeah. And I think it's also seeing from the other side as well, people interviewing you are really just human beings and people genuinely I think want to make interviews positive experiences so that you are able to express your own opinions and give the best of yourself. I think you know things have changed from the bad old past where interviews were perhaps set up to be quite terrifying and I think there's a lot more focus now on making interviews a positive experience for people because who wants to go and work somewhere they've been
开始大声说出来，认真对待自己，而不是对“我有观点”或“人们会想听我说话”这个想法感到畏缩时，我认为你才开始崛起。是的。而且我认为从另一面看也是如此，面试你的人真的只是普通人，我认为人们真心希望让面试成为积极的体验，这样你就能表达自己的观点并展现最好的自己。我认为你知道，情况已经从过去那种面试可能被设定为非常可怕的糟糕时代发生了变化，我认为现在人们更关注让面试成为一种积极的体验，因为谁想去一个他们被
terrorized by the interviewers. But yeah I think it's I like the way you say, you know, hearing your voice out loud and it's sometimes when I ask the first question, people are like, oh, oh, I don't really know what to say. And it's, you know, we all need a little bit of warming up, I think, of settling into an interview, but also settling into how to present oneself in an interview. It's not an easy process, but it's definitely something that you can improve upon with practice. So it's, I think it's really nice that you offer that. that practice as well. Yeah, I hear you. It isn't easy and there is that, you know, power imbalance, isn't there? They've got something that you want, although sometimes during an interview you're thinking, I don't want this. I've realised I don't want this job. But that's important as well because you're not just going and saying, hire me, hire me. You're going, especially if you're able to go for an in-person interview, you're going to see whether you think that they can be lucky enough to work with you or whether you'd like to do that. And even when you get offered a job,
面试官恐吓过的地方工作呢？但是，是的，我喜欢你说的，你知道，大声说出你的声音，有时当我问第一个问题时，人们会说，哦，哦，我真的不知道该说什么。而且，你知道，我们都需要一点热身，我认为，适应面试，也适应如何在面试中展示自己。这不是一个容易的过程，但通过练习，这绝对是可以改进的。所以，我认为你提供这种练习真的很好。是的，我明白你的意思。这并不容易，而且确实存在那种权力不平衡，不是吗？他们拥有你想要的东西，尽管有时在面试中你会想，我不想要这个。我意识到我不想要这份工作。但这也很重要，因为你不仅仅是去说，雇佣我吧，雇佣我吧。你是去，特别是如果你能去参加面对面的面试，你是去看看你是否认为他们有幸能与你共事，或者你是否愿意这样做。即使当你被录用时，
you don't have to say yes. I've been in the position of going along to interviews kind of speculatively to see what I think, to weigh up my options and, you know, having a few interviews and then kind of waiting to see what happens and really having an idea of what my first, my first best preference would be. And you don't have to say yes, even if you haven't got something else. If you think this is not going to be for you, you can say, you can say no, can't you. Absolutely. And it, you know, we spend a large amount of our time at work and it's, of course, everybody wants to get their first role. But, but if it, if it doesn't feel right for whatever reason, you know, as you say, that's, that's the purpose of an interview as well. It's for you to
你也不必说“是”。我曾经处于那种投机性地去参加面试以看看我的想法，权衡我的选择，你知道，参加了几次面试，然后等着看会发生什么，并且真正知道我首选的目标是什么。你不需要说“是”，即使你没有其他选择。如果你认为这不适合你，你可以说，你可以说“不”，不是吗？当然。而且，你知道，我们大部分时间都在工作，当然，每个人都想得到他们的第一份工作。但是，如果因为某种原因感觉不对，你知道，正如你所说，这也是面试的目的。这是为了让你
check out, is it, is it right for me? Is it going to work for me? And, you know, also in the case of perhaps students, graduates who need adjustments to be able to operate in the workplace. Some employers are better at providing those adjustments that they're absolutely legally entitled to. And so you're also checking out, is this going to be a supportive employer for me and my needs? So important. Are you seeing? So I feel like an important part of my podcast is about inclusivity and how not all psychologists look the same. You know, some may be, you know, able to walk on their who legs, others, you know, might look very different. And, you know, we've even had a recent
检查一下，它适合我吗？它对我有效吗？而且，你知道，对于那些在工作场所需要调整才能工作的学生、毕业生来说，有些雇主在提供他们绝对有法律权利获得的那些调整方面做得更好。所以你也在检查，这对我以及我的需求来说会是一个支持性的雇主吗？太重要了。你看到了吗？所以我感觉我的播客的一个重要部分是关于包容性，以及并非所有的心理学家看起来都一样。你知道，有些人可能，你知道，能够用他们的双腿行走，其他人，你知道，可能看起来非常不同。而且，你知道，我们最近甚至有
episode where we had a trainee psychologist who's registered Blyden uses a guide dog. I feel like we're really, I'm trying to amplify that psychologists can look all kinds of different ways and have all kinds of different experiences. Are you seeing more of that diversity coming through in more recent years? A little bit, and I'm all on board for more inclusivity. It's something that I feel really passionately about as well. Certainly in the NHS trust near the university that I work at, they run a program called Catalyst Program, which is a six-month assistant internship program that is aimed at students that would not otherwise be able to access work experience for whatever reason, so they wouldn't be able to voluntarily work. And of course, there could be many
一期节目，我们有一位注册盲人并使用导盲犬的实习心理学家。我觉得我们真的，我正在努力放大心理学家可以有各种不同的样子，并拥有各种不同的经历。你近年来是否看到更多的这种多样性出现？有一点，我完全支持更多的包容性。这也是我真正热衷的事情。当然，在我工作的大学附近的 NHS 信托基金中，他们运行一个名为“催化剂计划”的项目，这是一个为期六个月的助理实习项目，旨在帮助那些因某种原因无法获得工作经验的学生，所以他们无法进行志愿工作。当然，这可能有许多
reasons for that. Universities themselves run different schemes. So, At Brunall, we ran, unfortunately, we haven't got the funding this year, but I ran a very small internship program for, this wasn't psychology focus, but it was for students with any kind of disability or learning difference to gain an internship at the university. So we had kind of five students scattered around the university gaining experience that they could then put on their CVs. So there are pockets of money out there within universities and outside. They aren't always easy to find, but it's worth, again, checking with your career service to see if they know of any local initiatives that are running because the Catalyst Program run by the North, I think it's Northwest London Trust, it's an amazing program. And every year, I'm really like keeping my fingers crossed that it runs. So I'm keeping my fingers crossed that it runs in 2026. So there are things out there, but sometimes you have to dig around a little bit and ask the people in the people in the world. the know to see what's out there. But it's important, yeah. Sounds fantastic that Catalyst
原因。大学本身也运行不同的计划。所以，在布鲁内尔大学，我们运行过，不幸的是，我们今年没有资金，但我运行了一个非常小的实习项目，这不是心理学重点，而是为了让任何有残疾或学习差异的学生在大学获得实习机会。所以我们有大约五名学生分散在大学里获得经验，然后他们可以把这些经验写在简历上。所以大学内外都有一些资金。它们并不总是容易找到，但再次值得向你的职业服务部门查询，看看他们是否知道任何正在运行的当地倡议，因为由北部，我认为是伦敦西北信托基金运行的“催化剂计划”，是一个了不起的项目。每年，我真的都在祈祷它能运行。所以我祈祷它能在 2026 年运行。所以外面有这些东西，但有时你必须稍微挖掘一下，问问那些知情的人看看外面有什么。但这很重要，是的。听起来那个“催化剂”项目太棒了。
program. Just before I logged on and opened up this browser for us to speak, I was on LinkedIn because I often am. If you're not already connected with me on there, I'm Dr. Marianne, Chink, come and say hi. And I'd seen that someone had said, oh, after almost a year and, you know, a hundred applications. I'm delighted to be able to say that I've got my first assistant psychologist post. And I was like, amazing, incredible. I'd say you're going really well to have got your first AP post within a year of graduating because actually that isn't super common. So if people have done a placement year, that might speed them up a little bit. But when you're going for assistant psychologist roles, you're often competing against people that have already worked as a paid assistant
就在我登录并打开这个浏览器让我们交谈之前，我正在 LinkedIn 上，因为我经常在那里。如果你还没有在那里与我建立联系，我是 Marianne 博士，过来打个招呼。我看到有人说，哦，在将近一年和，你知道，一百份申请之后。我很高兴地说，我得到了我的第一份助理心理学家职位。我当时想，太棒了，不可思议。我会说你在毕业一年内得到你的第一份 AP 职位做得非常好，因为实际上这并不常见。所以如果人们做过实习年，那可能会加快他们的速度。但是当你申请助理心理学家职位时，你经常是在与已经作为带薪助理
psychologist, that might already have done a master's, that might already have done lots of relevant experience roles. So by the time I started as a paid assistant psychologist, I had been travelling around the world independently, I'd been a home carer, I'd work with students in the student support setting, I had worked in an office for probably getting on for a year, number of different offices and then I'd worked for a local council doing rehab and support work with disabled adults for two and a half years and then I got a paid role as an AP so people are like why aren't I getting this you know I've got my psychology degree but a psychology degree is not a golden ticket to an AP role is it Sam? No and I think the I think the job title misleads people
心理学家工作过的人竞争，他们可能已经完成了硕士学位，可能已经做了很多相关经验的工作。所以当我开始作为一名带薪助理心理学家时，我已经独立环游世界，我做过家庭护理员，我在学生支持环境中与学生一起工作过，我在办公室工作过大概快一年了，在许多不同的办公室，然后我为当地议会工作了两年半，做康复和支持残疾成年人的工作，然后我才得到了一份带薪的 AP 职位，所以人们会问为什么我没有得到这个，你知道，我有我的心理学学位，但心理学学位不是 AP 职位的金票，是吗，Sam？不，而且我认为，我认为职位名称误导了人们
I think this word assistant, often people believe, okay, so it's an entry level job. And as you say, it really, really isn't. But I think maybe if people, you know, just readjust their expectations, then they're, okay, so that's something I have to work towards. And, you know, I know you highlight that in your work, but it's something I'm frequently having to say, oh, okay, yeah, no, don't worry. The reason you're not getting these positions or these interviews is not because there's anything wrong with you it's just you know it's maybe you need a little bit more
我认为“助理”这个词，人们通常认为，好吧，这是一份入门级的工作。正如你所说，它真的，真的不是。但我认为也许如果人们，你知道，重新调整他们的期望，那么他们，好吧，所以这是我必须努力争取的东西。而且，你知道，我知道你在你的工作中强调了这一点，但我经常不得不说，哦，好吧，是的，别担心。你没有得到这些职位或这些面试的原因不是因为你有什么问题，只是你知道，也许你需要更多一点
experience first because it's not common to get that kind of position until a year two years after you've graduated I think I once heard of a student who had been offered a paid assistant psychologist role straight after graduating but that was simply because they had done a placement year within that service the service knew them and asked them if they wanted to come back but that is pretty much unheard of in my experience so so yeah it's about building up that experience before you apply for those roles and you know If people come to me and say, I want to apply, I want to apply now.
经验，因为在毕业一两年后才得到那种职位并不常见。我想我曾经听说过一个学生在毕业后直接被提供了一份带薪助理心理学家职位，但这仅仅是因为他们在该服务部门做过实习年，服务部门认识他们并问他们是否想回来，但在我的经验中，这几乎是闻所未闻的。所以，是的，这是关于在申请这些职位之前积累经验，而且你知道，如果人们来找我说，我想申请，我想现在就申请。
I'm like, great, you know, I'll always support you. Just be aware that it might be that, you know, just set your expectations that it might be this time you don't get through because it might be that you need a little bit more experience. And then, you know, you could use it as a practice if you don't get through this time. Absolutely, such good advice.
我会说，太棒了，你知道，我会一直支持你。只是要注意，可能，你知道，设定你的期望，这次你可能不会通过，因为可能你需要更多一点经验。然后，你知道，如果你这次没有通过，你可以把它当作一次练习。当然，这是非常好的建议。
And speaking of setting expectations, when I was at university, I was told in my final weeks of uni, don't bother clinical psychology. It's very hard. It's very difficult. Probably won't get on. It's very stressful. Don't do it to yourself.
说到设定期望，当我在大学时，我在大学的最后几周被告知，不要费心临床心理学了。这很难。这非常困难。可能进不去。这压力很大。别那样对自己。
And for me, I was like, well, no, that's that red ragged trouble. Like, no, that's not going to work for me. But, yeah, I guess talking about the fact that it is a challenging career, any of the HCPC psychologist routes are very challenging, but they aren't impossible. And someone's got to do it. You know, why not, why not you? Thank you for raising that point because I feel I love the fact that to you that inspired you to prove them wrong and to make it happen for yourself because, you know, people do these jobs. And yes, it may be a long journey. It may be difficult. It may not always go the way you want. You may not get on to the, you know, you may not get the assistant psychologist position straight away. You may never get an assistant psychologist position. That doesn't mean you can't be a clinical psychologist without it. There are different routes.
对我来说，我当时想，嗯，不，那就像红布对公牛一样。就像，不，那对我没用。但是，是的，我想谈谈它是一项具有挑战性的职业这一事实，任何 HCPC 心理学家的路线都非常具有挑战性，但它们并非不可能。总得有人去做。你知道，为什么不，为什么不是你？感谢你提出这一点，因为我感到我喜欢这样一个事实，即这激励了你去证明他们错了，并为你自己实现它，因为，你知道，人们确实在做这些工作。是的，这可能是一段漫长的旅程。这可能很困难。它可能并不总是按照你想要的方式进行。你可能不会直接得到助理心理学家的职位。你可能永远得不到助理心理学家的职位。这并不意味着没有它你就不能成为临床心理学家。有不同的路线。
And, you know, I have students who people say that same thing to them. And I think it's for people to decide their own goals and to decide what they want to do. And to hopefully find their own role models that they can relate to that can inspire them. And, you know, if for any of my students that are listening, if that's what you want, I will support you all the way. Because, you know, and some people may change their minds. in two, three years time and think, well, I've given it my all and actually my circumstance of change and that's not for me now. And, you know, whatever you choose at any given point in time
而且，你知道，我有学生，人们对他们说同样的话。我认为这是让人们决定自己的目标并决定他们想做什么。并希望找到他们可以联系并激励他们的榜样。而且，你知道，如果我的任何学生正在听，如果那是你想要的，我会一直支持你。因为，你知道，有些人可能会在两三年后改变主意，认为，好吧，我已经尽力了，实际上我的情况变了，现在那不适合我了。而且，你知道，无论你在任何特定时间选择什么
is, is okay for you. But as career consultants, we're here to help you kind of take steps forward and to try to achieve what you do want to achieve. And, you know, it can be important to just have a little backup in the back of your mind just in case you need it, but always go for what you want with the support and help of the people that know what you need to do to get there. And that's whether, you know, the misconception of the assistant psychologist comes in. I think often people get put off because they're like, well, I've applied for all these positions. I haven't been successful.
对你来说都是可以的。但作为职业顾问，我们在这里帮助你迈出前进的步伐，并尝试实现你确实想要实现的目标。而且，你知道，在脑海中有一个小小的备份以防万一很重要，但总是要在那些知道你需要做什么才能到达那里的人的支持和帮助下，去追求你想要的。这就是助理心理学家的误解所在。我认为人们经常因为他们想，好吧，我已经申请了所有这些职位。我没有成功，所以感到灰心。
Therefore, I'm never going to be an assistant psychologist. Well, maybe, you know, build that experience first and then apply for the assistant psychologist roles. It's difficult. It is. And you can never see what's going to come next, can you? So you never know if the next one. would have a different outcome. But that said, if you're feeling burned out from your pursuit,
因此，我永远不会成为助理心理学家。好吧，也许，你知道，先积累经验，然后再申请助理心理学家的职位。这很难。确实如此。而且你永远无法预见接下来会发生什么，不是吗？所以你永远不知道下一次是否会有不同的结果。话虽如此，如果你因为你的追求而感到精疲力竭，
it's okay to down tools and you might not be downing them forever. You might just be like, I'm just going to stay where I am or I'm going to do this job until I feel, it's a bit like an itch, you know, until you be like, oh, you know, you finish university and think I'm never going to study again, it's awful, lawful. And then one day you're like, hmm, I'd like to learn more about that and you find yourself Googling it and before you know you're signing yourself up to something. And I think the same is true with kind of learning and being in our roles. You know, we can be stretched and grown and be kind of energized and learning something new every day until you're not or until something turns your head and you're like, right,
放下手头的工作是可以的，而且你可能并不需要永远放下它们。你可能只是想，我就待在原地，或者我会一直做这份工作，直到我感觉……这有点像一种痒的感觉，你知道，就像你大学毕业时觉得我再也不想学习了，这太糟糕了，太可怕了。然后有一天你会想，嗯，我想多了解一下那个，于是你开始谷歌搜索，不知不觉中你就报名参加了什么课程。我认为在学习和职场中也是如此。你知道，我们可以不断扩展、成长，每天都充满活力地学习新东西，直到你不再这样，或者直到有什么东西吸引了你的注意力，你会想，好吧，
oh, okay. It's like when I first realized that I wanted a Volvo. You then see volvos everywhere, right? And it's like that. Like when you're ready for a new job or a new challenge, that activates you. And it allows you to see all of those opportunities, hopefully, around you. Yeah. And I think that's, you know, when you're thinking about what pathway you want to follow in a career, it's like, well, what am I naturally drawn to?
哦，好的。就像我第一次意识到我想要一辆沃尔沃时，你就会到处看到沃尔沃，对吧？就是那样。当你准备好迎接一份新工作或新挑战时，它就会激活你。它让你能够看到周围所有那些机会，希望如此。是的。我认为，当你思考职业生涯中想要走什么道路时，就像是，我天生被什么吸引？
What are the things that I follow on social media? What do I like Googling about? What do I like reading about? Where does my natural interest lie? And then, of course, as you say, those things will then come to you in abundance. But it's also paying attention to what do I want. What sparks my interest and where does my attention go naturally? Absolutely.
我在社交媒体上关注什么？我喜欢谷歌搜索什么？我喜欢阅读什么？我天生的兴趣在哪里？当然，正如你所说，这些东西随后会源源不断地来到你身边。但也要注意我想要什么。什么激发了我的兴趣，我的注意力自然会转向哪里？绝对是这样。
Thank you so much for your time and highlighting this very important aspect of what universities can do, maybe not even just for psychology, but whatever your degree is, there will be someone that specialising and looking out for you. So thank you so much for your time, Sam. Thank you so much for having me. It's been a really enjoyable discussion. It really has. Thank you very much. Thank you so much to Sam for sharing her time with us so kindly. And I'm kind of reflecting on the episode and it's making me think that actually, whilst I didn't need to work but did end up working during my undergrad. Many people are not in that position.
非常感谢你抽出时间，并强调了大学可以做的这个非常重要的方面，也许不仅仅是针对心理学，无论你的学位是什么，都会有人专门为你提供帮助。所以非常感谢你的时间，Sam。非常感谢邀请我。这是一次非常愉快的讨论。确实如此。非常感谢。非常感谢Sam如此慷慨地与我们分享她的时间。我在反思这一集，这让我想到，虽然我不需要工作，但在本科期间确实工作了。许多人并没有处于那种境地。
Many people are working a full-time job against what is essentially full-time study as well and having to squeeze their lectures in around shifts. And if you are having to do that, then, you know, please know that you are not alone. There are other people in that vote too. And my hat really goes off to you. And I really do admire you because you will not likely be able to have the same experience of university as some of your peers might be. You might well be out of bed earlier, into bed later, having to shoehorn your study and your
许多人一边做着全职工作，一边还要进行本质上是全职的学习，不得不把讲座挤在轮班之间。如果你必须这样做，那么，请知道你并不孤单。还有其他人也处于同样的境地。我真的向你们致敬。我真的很佩服你们，因为你们很可能无法像你们的一些同龄人那样拥有同样的大学经历。你们很可能起得更早，睡得更晚，不得不把学习和
seminars and your lectures into an already busy life. So I would love to know if this resonates with you. Please do let me know on social media. Please do share this episode to your stories if you have enjoyed. it, please do drop me a comment both on Spotify or on Apple. It would be so gratefully received. And if you have felt bad for me earning £45 a month from the podcast, then if you would like to support my costs as a creator to help me to be able to create this really valuable psychology careers content, please do consider maybe buying one of my books, The Aspiring Psychologist
研讨会以及讲座硬塞进已经很忙碌的生活中。所以我很想知道这是否引起了你的共鸣。请务必在社交媒体上告诉我。如果你喜欢这一集，请分享到你的故事中，请在Spotify或Apple上给我留言。我将不胜感激。如果你因为我从播客中每月赚取45英镑而为我感到难过，那么如果你想支持我作为创作者的成本，帮助我能够创作这些非常有价值的心理学职业内容，请考虑购买我的一本书，《有抱负的心理学家》
collective, the clinical psychologist collective, maybe even the grief collective or an autistic anthology, please do consider joining the aspiring psychologist membership if you're serious about moving your career forwards. And of course, you can join the channel either as a first look member or the backstage crew. And that is available on Apple Podcasts, Captivate or Patreon, and on YouTube. There's more information in the show notes, the description, and on link in my social media bias. Thank you so much. Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are
集体，《临床心理学家集体》，甚至可能是《悲伤集体》或《自闭症选集》，如果你认真想要推动你的职业发展，请考虑加入有抱负的心理学家会员。当然，你可以作为“先睹为快”会员或“后台工作人员”加入频道。这在Apple Podcasts、Captivate或Patreon以及YouTube上都有提供。更多信息在节目说明、描述以及我社交媒体简介的链接中。非常感谢。《心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，这让我感到惊讶
to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're a lot of, feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而且没有成为临床心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下这本书了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。